Speaker 1: All right, let's jump jump right
into this topic, it's a big topic, it's a
complicated one. Over the last several weeks,
I've gotten a ton of emails from you guys, calls
with people asking or suggesting maybe if
you are unvaccinated and you get very sick
with covid and you go to the hospital, you
should be refused treatment. And of course,
that's not going to happen in any real way.
There are primary care doctors that are saying
our practice will only treat what will only have
on a roster of vaccinated patients. But if you go
to an emergency room, you are not going to be
denied treatment because you are unvaccinated,
for better or worse, ethical, unethical. That's
just not going to happen. But there are now
new questions. It's a much more narrow discussion.
And the discussion is whether it would be fair
to treat vaccinated covid patients first. And
this is more of a triage conversation. So really,
it's a question of whether vaccination status
should or could be considered in terms of triage.
And there's some pretty good arguments to suggest
that it should, which we are going to get into
interesting Wired article, which asks, would it
be fair to treat vaccinated covid patients first?
Last week, tuks Texas health care policymakers
discussed taking vaccination status into account
for covid triage. It's a larger conversation
ethicists are bracing for. It's no accident
that people describe something that's calculated,
cold and unemotional as clinical. Taking care of
people's health isn't health isn't emotion free by
any means. But the clinic is where physicians and
nurses have to make life and death decisions under
time pressure, including which patients go first
and what kind of care they get when resources
like, say, ventilators or intensive care beds,
oxygen staff and time are scarce. That decision
making is called triage. And last week,
the Dallas Morning News reported that some Texas
hospitals were considering a massive change to
how they do it. The question in play, would it
make sense to take into account the vaccination
status of their covid patients with ICU filling up
with severely ill covid patients and a shortage of
beds and nurses should clinicians all other things
being equal? That's an important part of it.
Care for vaccinated people before or differently
than unvaccinated ones. And the article goes on
to say it hasn't happened and probably won't.
The idea came from a memo. This is this is a
very complicated question. Fundamentally, this is
not about ignoring the Hippocratic Oath and saying
don't treat unvaccinated patients. They haven't
taken care of themselves, assuming there's no real
medical reason why they're unvaccinated. We're
going to ignore these people, that that's not what
this is about. This is about including vaccination
status as part of triage, where someone may end up
getting less care or might end up getting no care,
depending on how full an emergency room is. In a
moment, I'll tell you about three emergency rooms
that are so full they've closed and whether the
vaccination status affects chance of recovery. And
you could on this basis say, all right, you've got
a 65 year old vaccinated patient and a 60 year old
unvaccinated patient. And if you don't consider
vaccination status, you might just go by how
severe are their symptoms, their age, etc..
If you consider vaccination status, you would have
this statistical framework in which you know that
hospitalized, vaccinated patients are more likely
to survive than unvaccinated patients. That would
be a way to empirically, not in some kind of
moralistic punishment way, but empirically
consider vaccination status in triage. Is a
vaccinated 50 year old more likely to recover
than an unvaccinated 40 year old? And there's even
another aspect of this, which is if you have a
patient in the E.R. or in the ICU or potentially
going into the ICU and they're unvaccinated
and they're unvaccinated for no other reason
other than they fell for conspiracy theories,
does it stand to reason that they may generally be
less likely to heed the advice that they are given
in that hospital if granted an intensive care
unit? Would it be fair to consider that as well?
And of course, there's there's the
important inclusion of the idea, all
else being equal. And really the I think the gist
here is not to make unclear triage calls about
a vaccinated 55 year old and an unvaccinated
40 year old, but really more about situations
where it's almost identical situations. You
might have two people equally sick. Same age,
one vaccinated, one unvaccinated, and you have
one spot in the ICU, would it be fair to say
we're going to take the vaccinated patient because
statistically they're more likely to recover
and in general, they are probably more likely to
heed our advice. This is not unheard of elsewhere
on the basis of a different sort of sort of health
considerations. Alcoholics historically have been
considered unsuitable for liver transplants
because of the presumed high risk of relapsing
to excessive drinking, which could ruin the
transplanted liver. That's that's a lifestyle
choice that is factored into organ donation,
although there are people who rightly say, well,
it's not really a lifestyle choice. Alcoholism is
a disease and then it becomes more complex. But
the point is that it is it's similar. It's
analogous to some degree. Triage is about
chances of survival, but it's also about available
resources. It's also about patient willingness to
comply with medical advice. And people who are
vaccinated are not only more likely to survive,
they've shown a motivation to follow the
widely accepted medical advice. And ultimately,
this is about available resources. And we've
talked before and I'm going to give you an example
in the next story of this. When you have a full
ICU with disproportionately unvaccinated people,
not because of a medical condition that says don't
get vaccinated, but because they've chosen not to
get vaccinated. If you get into a car accident,
if you have a heart attack, if you have a work
injury and you're vaccinated and you go in for
something serious, not related to covid, you may
not be able to get the treatment you need because
of people who have simply chosen not to get
vaccinated. And so there is an element of this,
which is that people who are not looking out for
society are consuming resources and hurting other
people, people who maybe would survive after that
car crash if they could get right into an ICU. But
the ICU is full because of unvaccinated people.
So I think it's completely reasonable to take it
into account in triage. I'm not saying you don't
provide treatment, but the question about triage
considerations seems completely logical to me.